today we're going to look at my favorite
puzzle it's involving squares rectangles
i've actually used this a few times in
the oxford university admissions
interview questions so it's got some
heritage behind it bit of prestige
behind this question i won't be using it
anymore because i'm going to tell you
all how it's done we're going to start
with a square like so and this can be
any size square it doesn't really matter
and what we want to do
is fill the square with rectangles now
the rectangles can be of any size as
well but they have a rule that they have
to be in the ratio
two
to one so this doesn't mean this is
length two and this is length one this
could be length uh let's say this was
two quarters and then oh i should have
picked a better number and this one
needs to be one quarter so we could have
smaller ones and really tiny ones it
doesn't matter the size of the rectangle
they just have to be in this ratio long
side is twice the length of the short
side and what we want to do is fill the
square with these rectangles and we're
interested in
for what numbers of rectangles is it
possible to fill the square so clearly
for one it isn't because a rectangle in
this ratio two to one is not a square so
you can't just fill it with one
so we can say for n equals one that's a
big no but then for n equals two it's
going to work because i can just do that
if we say the squares one by one then
both of these rectangles are one by a
half twice in the ratio and we can fill
it with two so n equals two
is a tick and that was n equals one was
the cross
and we want to know for what other
values
can we do this is it possible for any
other values can we do it for all of
them
that's the question can we figure this
out
so you can use duplicates obviously yes
we can use the so here we've got two of
the same size i could have it doesn't
have to all be the same size so that's
important we could have one big one and
i don't know six small ones or something
or maybe like four different size
rectangles there's no limit in the size
of the specific rectangles or the
numbers of each one
just we're interested in the total
number of rectangles that fill the
square as long as they're in this ratio
so is the puzzle question for which
numbers can we do it or is the question
can you do it for all numbers or like i
i always thought i would present it as
for which numbers can we do it but
within that we're kind of saying can we
do it for all numbers are there some
numbers other than one where it doesn't
work
but we're going to hopefully we're going
to try and consider all possible values
that's that's the goal we're going to
actually try and consider every single
number so the way i would approach a
problem like this is
well there's two options the way i see
it so so we've shown so far it's not
going to work for one because then it
would be a square and we've shown that
we can do it for two so you could
continue in this way and say well let's
try and do it for three let's try and do
it for four
but the problem is
if you hit a number where it doesn't
work
you've got to show it doesn't work
you've got to like try everything like
you have to exhaust
all possible
ways of arranging rectangles and it's
really difficult to exhaust every single
possible thing that you can do
in such an open
problem like this
so
my suggestion would be to think well can
i find something else that works that
isn't two
let's try and get another handle on the
problem and see if we can use that to
build other cases if we start with the
two that we had we had a square and we
divided it into two so if i now divide
this bottom rectangle into two squares
i've now got a square that i can divide
into two and another square that i can
divide into two and lo and behold we've
got a solution so we've got five there n
equals five is a tick so we took what we
had which was two and then sort of broke
it down so i call this the breaking down
method
into
uh one of them we broke it up first into
two squares and then copied what we did
at the start
to get four so we replaced one rectangle
by four rectangles so in total we added
three to our two that we started with
now there's nothing stopping me from
doing this again and again and again so
i can pick one of my five rectangles
divide it into two squares and then
divide each square
into two rectangles and now i should
have eight one two three four five six
seven eight so now we get n equals eight
is a solution and i could have of course
picked another rectangle and divided
that up i could have picked the top one
and then i would have got a solution
where we had eight all of the same size
but remember we're not interested in the
specific configuration we just care
about the number of rectangles is it a
tick or is it a cost i can continue to
do the same
thing so if i continue with this bottom
left one two squares
two rectangles and i've added i've
replaced one rectangle by four so i've
added three
so that would be eleven
and i can do the same again so there's
the last one i'll show you because i'm
running out of space and i can just
continue this and again i don't have to
keep picking this one we can keep adding
three so we get 14 we get 17 we get 20
23. to come back to the original
question for which how many like ways
can we do this we now have an infinite
number
of ways to fill a square with these two
by one rectangles because we just keep
adding three and we can just go on
forever but we're missing quite a few
there's a lot of gaps there's almost
like twice as many gaps as there are
numbers we're hitting because we're
hitting every other third
number
so what we want to try and do now is
think about well how could we hit
those numbers this method i called the
the breaking down method because we took
a solution that we had and then we broke
down a rectangle and added three to the
total and then the other approach i'm
calling the building up because what
we're going to do is again start with
our square and we want to now add
rectangles around the outside but so
that the final shape is a square because
remember the square can be any size so
if we try and build up you think about
this a little bit and again you should
do this you can
kind of create an overhang like this on
all four sides
you can hopefully see that's possibly
going to work it could maybe be a square
um so again if we take the middle one to
be one and this one to be half so the
middle square was one by one then what
we've got here is this length is two and
then this one to be in the correct ratio
has to be one so we do indeed have a
square we've got two different sizes of
rectangle two in the middle and then
four of this second size where the
square that we fill in total is going to
be three squared but it's built up of
six rectangles so now we've got a
different solution six we didn't have
the four and just like before we can
keep doing this and building up so you
could just do that
and you could figure out the numbers
he's gonna be a bit bigger again and
you're gonna keep doing this and we keep
adding
four every time so we've got six then we
can say that we can do this now for ten
and we add another four to get 14
18
22 26 30. so we have another infinite
list of possible solutions and some of
these numbers are the same we've got 14
in both lists but also you know we've
got 10 which we didn't have we've got 18
22. we've got new numbers as well so
there's some overlap but we've got
another
way
of constructing these solutions
like before
in this first case
we said that what we were doing was we
were adding three every step
and you can think of this as saying
well if i have a solution for
n for some number
then i know from our method here the
breaking down method i can take one of
the rectangles in the solution divide it
up into four smaller rectangles and that
added three to our solution so if we had
a solution for n
we can always get n plus three
from the breaking down and then here
we've seen the same thing because we
started with two and i added four around
the edge but if i started with the five
solution here then i add four around the
edge and then i add another four so i
can also get for example there i would
get n equals nine plus four on that so
then i'd get 13
17 21 etc
and again we're getting some numbers we
didn't have the breaking down method
if we can do it for n we always get n
plus three break one of them into four
pieces the building up method if we can
do it for n
we can always do it for n plus four and
now these two are really powerful rules
so we're already seeing that we've got a
lot of solutions but if we actually
think about this mathematically now
using the algebra
we can begin to see that we actually get
almost all of the numbers
so i think the best way to demonstrate
this is sort of write out the list of
the first 30 numbers and cross off the
ones we can and can't do and then we'll
think about can we prove this so we know
that one didn't work i think that's the
only one we know that doesn't work
we showed that two did we haven't looked
at three or four we had five uh we had
six we haven't covered seven yet i think
we had eight yes eight was the five plus
three nine we got down here by doing
five and then four around the outside
then we had ten on our list now we've
got something really helpful here
because we've got three numbers in a row
so because i've got 8
i know that i can just add 3 to it
and get 11.
because i've got 9 i can add 3 to it
and get 12. because i've got 10 i can
add 3 to it
and get 13. and then this is just going
to carry on so you can look back through
our lists as well and see you know we
had 14 17 and you could tick them off
but if you spot that because we had
these three numbers in a row
then and we have this m plus three rule
we're actually going to get all of the
other numbers so there's lots of ways of
spotting that you're gonna get all the
other numbers but however you do it it
relied on the fact that we had well
actually only really this rule the n
plus three once we figured out that we
could get eight nine and ten so we did
need building up
to get some of these right so nine and
ten came from the building up method and
eight came from the breaking down so we
did need the second method but really we
just needed the m plus three rule
plus those three
and then we got all of the numbers so
that just leaves us with three
four
and seven
so we know that one's impossible we know
that every single other number is
possible now except three four and seven
so we've got to figure these ones out
and this is this he's got to do this
case by case i'm gonna need more paper
aren't i i have no intuition as to
whether three four or seven are possible
this is how i think about it
we're gonna consider three we're gonna
say right let's try and find a solution
for three suppose we can do that
and you want to think about the number
of corners
in your square one two three four
corners and we have three rectangles for
example let's take one of our rectangles
suppose it hits all four
corners
it's clearly got to be a square and
there's clearly no space for the others
so you cannot have one of your
rectangles hitting all four corners
similarly
you cannot have one of your rectangles
hitting three corners because if one
rectangle hits three corners it kind of
has to hit the four and it kind of has
to be a square again
so the highest number of corners a
single rectangle can hit
is two
and in fact one of them has to hit two
because there's only three rectangles
and four corners
so
categorically we can say one of the
rectangles must cover two of the corners
of our square and so the only way to fit
that is to divide it in half if we're
trying to find a solution for n equals
three this is completely fixed there's
nothing else that can happen
so then we've got to fill the remaining
space
with two rectangles so now
we've got two rectangles and we've got
four corners again so okay it's a
rectangle instead of a square but the
corners is a really helpful way to get
stuck into this problem because they've
all got to be touched so now you say
right i obviously can't hit all four
because then i'd fill it it would work
but i've got one rectangle left i can't
hit three for the same reason so i have
to hit two and each of them has to hit
two if you take a one by one square this
is a half so this one has to be a
quarter it's the only way you can fill a
rectangle thing two corners so then what
we're left with this has to be a
rectangle
and if we figure it out this is three
quarters this is a half it's certainly a
rectangle but it's not in our ratio one
to two so that doesn't work and so n
equals three doesn't work three is
getting
crossed out now four you do in basically
the same way start with your square you
say you've got four corners we can't
we've got four rectangles similar
argument one of them has to touch two
because if each one touches one you can
play around with it a bit but you'll see
that it doesn't work it kind of has to
be four square
the only way you can get it to work and
it doesn't doesn't fit our rules so
again you have to have
one of them like this touching those two
corners
so this is out
and then you're left now with three
rectangles to fill
this half we've got four corners three
rectangles same argument as before
except now we're on a rectangle we have
to touch two so it has to be this one
half by a quarter again and then we've
got the same space you can play around
with this as much as you want if you put
one horizontally it has to go the same
size a half and a quarter and that's
obviously a square or if you go
vertically down this won't work because
this is a quarter and this one here is
three quarters that would be one to
three ratio not one to two so four for
the same reason really as three ain't
gonna work cross it off so it all comes
down to seven this is the big finale of
our infinite list of numbers for solving
my favorite rectangle puzzle can we do
it for n equals seven
uh and the answer maybe surprisingly is
yes
we can do it it is possible for seven
it's quite tricky for those of you who
really want to give this a go
this is the time have a go it's it's
very fun trying to do this the trick
with solving it for seven
or the way we do it is we actually need
three different size
rectangles we'll say this is a one by
one square so i can convince you all
that this works so it doesn't look like
it's gonna work at first so to start
with we have one
big rectangle that's gonna be our half
by one so you'll notice this is the
building block of almost all of our
ideas actually and then you have
three
little guys so this is gonna have to be
a third for each of them and the height
here to be in the ratio one to two is
one sixth we have another one here and
then we put another two here this is a
third
uh that would be one-sixth and that will
be a half
so we can check one six that would be
two six three six so that's one that
works this bit here is one-sixth
this one's one-sixth so that fits to be
one-third
and then this gap here this top long
side is two-thirds and this one's
one-third and we're done so we've got
five
of these small ones
one middle-sized one
and one big one and that is the solution
for n equals seven
n equals seven yeah we can solve it for
all
possible values of n we can fill our
square with n rectangles in this ratio
two to one except for one three
and four
all right
so now anyone who watch this video can
get into oxford
yes i use this question for the last two
years actually so so that's why i've had
to retire it because uh we i tried to
come up with new questions but i like
this one so much that actually this is
the only question i've used on repeat
but it's now been retired but yeah this
is this is the kind of thing because
there's lots going on there's lots to
think about lots of things to check and
you could if you wanted go as fancy as
you want in your proof with modular
arithmetic or spotting the pattern
there's a lot to get stuck into
today's episode sponsor is brilliant and
no matter who you are they're going to
have a course for you i love how
brilliant are really upping their game
on interactivity it always helps with
learning and understanding what you're
looking at now are just the opening
exercises in their massive course on
mathematical fundamentals it's just
great stuff i love the style that clean
look i also really like how everything
unfolds at my pace at the speed that i
understand things that's what the
interactivity is all about i never
really think of brilliant as being like
school or study it's more like a a
series of fun puzzles but each puzzle
was secretly giving you a deeper
understanding of mathematics or science
to check this stuff out yourself go to
brilliant.org
number file
using that slash number file will tell
them you came from here and also give
you 20 percent of a premium subscription
brilliant.org slash number file it's
well worth your time
i didn't keep drawing rectangles until i
got that one to work um but you know the
good the good students the good
candidates will be able to to get
through and spot the pattern with the
adding of three and like that's the key
thing really i think in terms of the
math behind this is spotting that
pattern